hey everybody welcome back to full hour
today I'll be working on some very
general stuff not necessarily detailing
but just some more large skilled and
less detailed things that might not look
good but are still super important and
actually something that I feel is much
more important than all of the
ridiculous details and overly intricate
scenery pieces that make up most of the
way that this project looks I'll be
mostly getting into actually planning
some buildings and doing a bit of more
or less more studying to test out how I
want to play certain things on the
island which to me is the most important
thing and I definitely want to get into
this video a little bit more as I do it
and as I am actually showing off the
ways in which I'm building all sorts of
walls around the island but first I want
to very quickly say that if I haven't
terrible while I'm recording this I have
a cold
and I wanted to ascend from recording
any videos during that period but you
know I didn't have anything saved which
is also kind of why there's been a
terrible lack of videos recently but
there is no way that I can get around
doing this with a cold
I've waited just about long enough for
this but at this time both of my
nostrils are sort of open so I'm just
trying to catch this opportunity while I
still can and hopefully it'll be all
good again soon not necessarily because
of my health there is no reason to worry
about that literally everybody in the
Netherlands has a bad cold right now it
just kind of sucks that I don't really
have my voice to be as good as it
usually should be anyway that's just a
small issue that I hope you don't mind
too much in the rest of this video
though the focus is going to be on what
I'm building and not what I'm just going
to be complaining about so the stuff
that I was mostly very worried about
when I started this series and I can't
even pronounce the word worried anymore
I don't know why I always have such
trouble with that you'll probably notice
that
in every one of my videos but what I was
very cautious about I guess in this
entire series is how I put down all of
the buildings like all of a different
mass of the towers and the dome and all
of the actual building meat that is
going to connect all of these things
because as nice as all the details and
things like that are I think detailing
is actually not the most important thing
to making build some of my favorite
builds are not necessarily very detailed
at all and I think really the most
important thing is that you set up the
composition well and while this usually
revolves around general park layouts and
how certain buildings work together like
for example one of my favorite things
I've ever done is still some of the
first buildings I've ever built in a
game for the station of the coaster in
grizzly Valley because even though it
might look terrible by today's standards
I just like the composition the way that
the buildings work together the way that
all of the dimensions work in the
buildings just about feels right and
that is a very important thing that I
feel is sometimes overlooked because
it's so very basic to how everything
else is going to look you could have a
very terrible composition of buildings
or parts of buildings and it would just
be a waste of time to add all this
detail to it because you're essentially
just putting sprinkles over a pile of
poo and while there's definitely no kind
of subjective way to look at
however ways buildings are composed or
whatever the dimensions are there is
still a general sort of idea of whatever
feels right or it looks good
and that is what I wanted to get to in
this series it's also why me getting a
nice feel for the way that buildings are
put together doesn't so much revolve
around me planning the buildings on
paper and working out exactly how I want
to lay out everything before I do it but
that's also kind of why I
to all of my quote/unquote planning in
game so you'll see me a lot of the times
this kind of messing with route lights
like adjusted or placing balls and
looking at that wall from every single
angle just to see how it fits into the
entire picture and only after I've done
all of that and all of the walls are put
together do I ever want to get into
detailing so a lot of this in this
episode is just kind of like you do
painting just try some stuff and taking
a distance again and seeing what it
looks like and how everything fits
together and if it works just kind of
move on to the next part occasionally I
do want to detail though because when it
comes to sort of planning your stuff
ahead like this there are definitely
some things that really dictate the look
of a certain thing for this tower for
example I did want to get into some of
the detailing of it just because having
the top part of this tower actually
finished gives a much better and much
clearer idea of how this tower would fit
into the whole when it is actually
finished and then the rest of the tower
like the lower part which is a
[ __ ] with the coaster track and
details like rhinos and stuff is
something that I feel safe getting into
later on because it doesn't so much
dictate the way that this color looks as
the top part does so yeah that's just
much of my work and that's also why in a
lot of my stuff in Flemish coaster I
rarely ever draw out things because I
just feel so much better
getting an idea of how things are going
to look in game and I spend a lot of my
mum time-lapse time just placing stuff
removing it again because it doesn't
look good moving at 10 centimeters and
looking at it again just that kind of
trial and error process to see how
everything should fit together it can be
very boring at parts but I think it is
quite important and not everything is
just endlessly detailing I suppose in
that sense but the way that the entire
picture comes
for me is still the most important part
so yeah I'm taking quite a bit of time
for that I'm actually starting to be a
bit concerned about how long this
project is still going to take because
it is it is an infamously annoying
project of mine that I kind of do love
and hate at the same time problem where
the project like this for me personally
and and also kind of the reason why I
wouldn't so much recommend doing it is
that it just feels overly ambitious and
by the time I'm working on a lot of
these things I'm not really innovating
anymore and that's a pretty big problem
for me I've actually had a comment about
this recently as well that there's been
kind of a lack of innovation on the
channel at least in terms of the
contents of what I'm doing in planet
coaster since a lot of it is still very
much the same and I'm very much training
around that you know I've already thread
I've already threaded with some of the
earlier episodes of opera and now I'm
just sitting out the ride in a sense and
that's just the annoying part of this it
is a very time-consuming thing that's
sort of based on this end image of how
it should look in the end but a lot of
the ways in which you come at that are
already established at a very early part
so the earliest episodes already
established what the rest of the
episodes are going to look like and
there's no opportunity to delve into new
themes there's no way to as you would in
a small park that you're building with
multiple areas there's no way to delve
into a new area and try some new things
and get innovative everything just has
to fit together and it's just a
continuation of what I already have and
in that sense I kind of feels like it's
holding me back I want to sit out this
ride for sure because I still want to
finish that image of what I intended
what what I set out to do when I started
this series I just can't help but feel
like you know there are some other
things I could have built in this time
that maybe would have been really cool
and innovative that I couldn't do
because I'm working on Silveira and if
that sounds very pretentious and Stu
it definitely is it's just one of the
reasons why I find it sometimes hard to
work on this thing even though I like
the way it is working out so far and I
really would still want to see that end
image which is just a good motivation
there's just something about this that
is kind of hard to do with that actually
did remind me with something that
important to talk about because I
thought it was actually very interesting
on the freakonomics podcast on how to be
productive
there was a small talk about how
productive you are when you're trying
something new versus how productive you
are when you try something that you're
already good at or that you already have
a lot of experience with and it turns
out that it's actually a lot easier to
be productive at something where you
still have to figure everything out then
when everything is already established
and you already know how to gather
things which definitely sounded super
counterintuitive but it actually
perfectly connect to an idea which I've
been having about games like these for
quite a while when it comes you know not
really to productivity because this is a
game in the end and you know you're just
playing it for fun but perhaps more to
creativity and how much you can actually
achieve in the game in whatever time
you're playing it because I also feel
that in this game if you're trying a new
theme or if you're trying a completely
new idea or concept you're better at it
initially then you are eventually when
everything sort of settles down and
you're used to the theme and you're used
to the way this work and I never really
was able to like pin this down but a lot
of it probably does come from the fact
that when you are going through
something and when you are just trying
something out you try everything out you
want to look at everywhere you can do a
certain thing you want to try your best
actually understand this thing and see
the ways in which you can work with it
so for example if I want to try out the
Japanese theme which I did a long time
ago but still the first time I ever
tried it out I looked
so much information about this I was
super inspired because it's something
that I've never really done before but
it was also something that I figured hey
this looks really amazing I I actually
got into talks with people about like
how it works what the ideas are behind
it so many Google Images pictures and so
many blogs and stuff about Japanese
architectures that just got me so
inspired about it and once I started
working in game which at the time I
guess was roller-coaster country I just
had all of these ideas on what to do and
I wanted to make sure that everything I
did I did in the best way and I just
took a lot of time to figure stuff out
and while that did make me sort of
unproductive in that sense it also
created some of my favorite things and I
guess the same goes for fara as well
which might be a great example before
the first episode I looked at a lot of
concepts things like that I was really
trying out everything and I was just
constantly coming up with new ideas even
though I was also very new to the
concept of the flying island of doing
things this way of using all of these
pieces for a steampunk theme so it was
something that I didn't really have
experience with and yet I feel like the
first episodes we're still the fastest
and the best ways made constantly coming
up with new ways to use the objects and
with new ways to integrate them in a
steampunk team and now that everything
is settled and I've already done all of
those things everything is just going
down unloads and it's more sitting out
the ride than actually doing things and
this is not really based on anything
it's just an idea that I've had and it's
very possible that you think about it in
a completely different way or that it
works for you in a completely different
way but for me at least I feel like very
often exploring a new theme or exploring
a new idea gets you a lot more motivated
to work a lot harder be quicker and
better at it than just doing something
that you're already experienced
and the same just goes for a game which
is you know it's just a sandbox game
what the hell am I talking about but
it's I feel like it works in the same
way and at this point that's also why I
want to keep my parks quite small why I
want to keep the areas in my parks quite
small and why I tend to hope so much
from project to project this is also
probably why so many people tend to just
start on a project do some really really
good stuff on it and then feel like
they're stuck and don't really do
anything anymore I think most of the
parks and coast is that all the people
killed just kind of end up in this sort
of half-finished States where you're
happy with it but you're also like well
now I kind of want to do something else
already and it's that kind of thing
which I just started thinking about
today and the reasons why it happens
then I just feel like you might just be
more productive where you're starting
something new then when you're already
experienced at it in this sort of weird
sense I mean there there were studies to
prove it but then again I'm not sure
about the validity validity of any of
those studies and I know an expert on
this whatsoever I just thought that was
a very interesting thing to think about
and something that did resonate with me
when it comes to pivara anyway to come
back to the game for a little bit and
leave the philosophy behind as well I
did a little bit of detailing around the
side of the coaster here since these are
really the hard part of making the
coaster so far I've just built a lot of
the very important parts like the tower
and the dome but they all end up with
very loose ends literally the lower
parts of the dome is just a giant open
gaping hole which has all of the weird
Cena me see Nuri sticking out and poking
through all of the walls the bottoms of
the towers just kind of float halfway
through all of the scenery and it is one
big mess so I'm trying to start here
already on sort of
cleaning up this mess that is all those
stuff that comes together I wouldn't say
that it's a bad idea to build your stuff
like this I definitely like it and it's
definitely important to make sure your
most important like visual parts of
whatever are out there and working
before you move into the very small
mixing crannies that you have to fill
stuff anyways but um it can be kind of
challenging at times to try and fit all
of this stuff together
this project has always also been a bit
of an experiment in how compact override
I can really fit in with as much scenery
on a very very small floating island
because really this footprint of this
ride is super tiny and if you were to
draw it out of the context and put it on
the ground it would be nearly a family
right that just sort of weaves in and
out of itself it's very compact and that
just makes the entire thing that little
bit more challenging but yeah basically
I'm just trying to figure out how I can
finish all of these little nooks and
crannies make sure that the dome doesn't
end up with this super weird high parts
where all the scenery sticks through
each other and where everything looks
messy but at some point in the future
hopefully this is all clean so the last
part here was just kind of cleaning
everything up and making sure that
everything connected somehow there will
definitely still be some open areas like
some little holes between the buildings
that aren't properly cleaned up but at
least around the roller-coaster
everywhere all the walls should be
pretty flush with each other and there
shouldn't be any of those weird scenery
things sticking out but that's all just
part of the challenge of trying to build
that stupidly compact coaster on a small
floating island anyway that's it for
this episode I am quite happy with how
the composition turned out and it
definitely gives a very good head start
for the next episode and I hope you guys
enjoyed see you later
[Music]
you